hey it's Alex and today I'm gonna what
another one is though this recipe is a
recipe I created it for all you
lovebirds out there on Valentine's Day
and I guess if you're single - you could
eat the whole thing so I really wanted
to make a video that was more than just
one recipe but a full dinner or a
romantic date like a date on Valentine's
Day so this is a meal that you could
create for your loved one that is not
only easy and doable but impressive and
sexy is shrimp sexy so I wanted to make
three recipes a appetizer a main and a
dessert that we're simple enough to nail
but also special enough to make it just
a little bit fancier than like a normal
weeknight meal you know on Valentine's
Day we go all out - tricky part about
making a three-course meal is that I
really wanted them all to kind of flow
together and taste good together so for
the appetizer I chose a bacon-wrapped
green bean bundle this was actually a
really cool-looking visual appetizer I
wanted it to not only taste really good
and have a flavors work well together
but for it to look really cool so
basically you just take a bunch of green
beans and adopt and bacon and you cook
it down you make a little sauce in the
pan and it all comes together for this
kind of like caramelized sugary bacon
then you got your veg in there - with
the green beans so you hit a lot of
bases on this appetizer so if you're
gonna have green beans or asparagus or
some sort of vegetable usually it's just
on the side of the plate and slap it on
but with this there's some extra care
and love that goes into it it's all
about the thought that counts moving on
to the main dish the main event one
would say shrimp scampi so this
definitely is like a decadent menial
because you've got the linguini you got
the butter
it's like rich I love a good shrimp
scampi cuz it's basically like shrimp
and butter and garlic lots of flavor in
there but it's also so easy to
because shrimp cooks like that so for
this scampi we use linguine they use of
the linguine just kind of elevates the
dish a little makes it different than
just your average spaghetti and again
this night is all about the stuff and
finally save the best for last
we've got dessert what is more on brand
with Valentine's Day than the classic
chocolate strawberry I again wanted to
keep each dish pretty simple just
because if you're making three dishes
you got a lot to do but we went the
extra mile and added a little more
chocolate in the center by shelling out
the middle and filling it so you not
only have a chocolate-dipped strawberry
you got a chocolate filled chocolate
strawberry double chocolate double the
fun so this is a very simple dessert
it's definitely a favorite choice for
Valentine's Day chocolate strawberries
you really can't get much sexier than
that
and you know what we're all about no
waste here so when you're making it eat
the Centers of the strawberries as you
go or you could like freeze them put
them in the freezer make it in a
smoothie
you know there's so many different ways
you could so don't throw those away I
don't have any Valentine's Day plans
this year maybe I'll make this meal for
myself I really wanted to make this
video as a special almost all the lovers
out there on Valentine's Day but if it's
not Valentine's Day or Valentine's Day
is not your thing you could still make
any one of these dishes and they'll
still be just as good so you guys out
there you should make this for your date
on Valentine's Day if you don't have a
date make it for yourself even better
we're all about self-love remember it's
a thought that goes
[Music]